scotland's claims credit for giving is
television penicillin and some of the
biggest ideas that shaped how we live
today it's also home to an independence
movement that refuses to die in 2014
Scott's got a vote did they want to
break away from England and the rest of
the United Kingdom 55% voted no but that
was less like an end than the start of
something new a change in Scottish
politics so here's the situation a large
part of the reason why Scotland rejected
independence in 2014 was fear fear the
economy wasn't strong enough to strike
out alone fear jobs were at risk Thea
ties to the European Union would be cut
fast forward to 2016 and when the UK
voted to leave the EU overwhelmingly
Scotland voted to stay as things stand
Scotland faces the prospect of being
taken out of the EU of against or will I
regard that as democratically
unacceptable First Minister Nicola
Sturgeon enjoys widespread support at
home to bargain on behalf of Scotland
membership and her independence touting
Scottish National Party exploded after
the 2014 referendum from 25,000 members
on the day of the vote to a whopping 115
thousand in April 2016 in the 2015
general election the SNP won all but
three of 59 Scottish seats in UK
Parliament making it the third largest
political party in Westminster and now
Breck's has given the cause another
boost
so is this Scotland's chance at
independence finally here's the argument
nationalists say the United Kingdom
Scotland voted for two years ago isn't
the United Kingdom that's on offer now
for them brexit changes everything this
is the opportunity that the movements
been waiting for albeit in less than
ideal circumstances a second
independence referendum is clearly an
option that requires to me on the table
and it is very much on the table but
while brexit may have sped up the
possibility of another run at
independence for Scotland it's also made
the prospect of it far trickier
opponents say the economic case for
independence is even worse now than it
was in 2014
since Scotland's economy would be
underpinned by North Sea oil they say
the plunging crude prices proves that
going it alone is too risky and
questions remain about what would happen
to Scotland's trade with the rest of the
UK which forms more than half of all
exports far more than those to the EU
even if Scotland gets as far as
independence it will still need to
convince EU member states it's worthy of
joining the club and it's uncertain how
sympathetic some EU members might be if
they're battling separatist movements of
their own